recently someone asked me what the most
important element of a business slide
presentation is and after thinking about
it for a bit it was very clear to me
that action titles are actually the most
important elements so if by now you're
not really sure what an action title is
or how to come up with a very very
strong action title welcome to another
video here on my channel firm learning
my name is heinrich i'm a former
mckinsey consultant and on my channel i
talk a lot about topics such as career
success and also consulting skills and
surely as a consultant one thing that
you really need to do well is to create
slight presentations in powerpoint or
any of these other programs so in
today's video i want to sharpen your
understanding why action tits are so
important and also give you some very
very tangible tips including an exercise
to help you come up with the best
possible action titles that you can
write for your slides let's start by
looking into why action titles are so
important and the key point here to
understand is that your presentations
should have a storyline and it is the
action titles that bring this story to
life the main idea is that if you read
your titles of your presentation from
start to end so every single slide just
read the titles the key idea is that by
just doing that you will be able to
understand all the key messages of the
presentation just by reading these
action titles so why is this even
necessary why is this important we try
to put yourself into the shoes of a
c-level manager you are a ceo cfo any
other business unit had any other senior
guy in an organization likely especially
these large blue chip companies that
often these consulting firms work for
these c-level people every single day
every single week they will get several
big documents 50 pages 100 pages or even
more of other projects that are going on
project updates progress reports
deliverables like that this is far too
much to read people like this cannot
just read every single slide of
documents like that so what they will
expect you to deliver is a document
where they can just skim through just
read the action titles and just by
reading the action titles be able to
understand all the key messages and this
is the so-called horizontal logic the
storyline of the presentation this needs
to come to life via the action titles
and then the idea is of course that if
they read something in the action title
that is really interesting
where they want to learn more about then
they stop and then they read the page
they read the full slide this then is
the vertical logic and here of course
you already understand one key thing
when writing strong action titles and
this is that of course an action title
should summarize the contents of a slide
in a clear and concise way so this is
the intuition but now you might ask
yourself well what exactly is an action
title so i try to put down here in
definition this is coming from myself so
no fancy source just my best way of
putting it in writing and i would define
an action title by being a header of a
slide presentation that summarizes the
content of the slide by formulating a
complete sentence so if you wanted
something like here the header also here
on top of this slide saying action
titles help to create the storyline
within the presentation this would be
the action title of that slide this is
what you want to try to achieve but what
do you write in such a title what are
the contents supposed to be and here i
think the best test that you can do is
the test of the so called so what the
question of the so what and i once
created a full video just about the
concept of asking this question so what
i will link it somewhere about here if
you're interested to learn more about
this feel free to check it out but in a
nutshell the so what is a question that
you as a project lead might ask to an
associated consultant who prepared a
slide or maybe a partner asked to you
and this person looks at your slide and
asks him or herself the question
so what right so so what why is this
irrelevant what is the implication of
what i see here because maybe the
information on the slide is interesting
it's data it's nice but what does this
mean for the problem at hand for the
thing that i need to solve so when
putting together the document you should
ask yourself what is this so what of
this light if you really struggle to
come up with this or what then this
often is a sign that this light maybe
isn't that important right it does not
have a clear so watch maybe it's
something that rather belongs in the
appendix but maybe not in the main deck
or maybe take it out completely but once
you know this so what make sure that
this award is clearly stated in the
action title and then of course when
you're presenting the slide then this
award is also what you should be
communicating in your presentation now
let's look into a couple of best
practices that you should apply whenever
you write an action title and here we'll
always have an example and then an
insight that i want to draw out from
that the first example is
managing risk is important for this
project's success and your mindset is
try to avoid statements like that try to
avoid writing general truths that are
pretty much always correct so of course
managing risks is pretty much always
important for this project's success
right so for almost every project that
will be relevant so try to avoid writing
things that are obvious really draw out
more insightful things than that
next something like all divisions have
found to not be following best practices
what's often dangerous is to write
action titles with really hard absolute
statements
always never in every case this is like
this or like that so these very hard
statements often are traps because there
are often some weird edge cases maybe
there is this like very little division
somewhere who does something that you
are not aware of just my personal
learning that often then especially if
you're presented maybe there's like one
board member sitting in the audience who
will tell you no but this is not correct
this is wrong because you know it's just
enough to have one example that
contradicts this and then pretty much
you're there i need to admit that yes
your message was wrong what you put on
the slide was wrong it's not the case
that this is true for all divisions next
one company has potential to
significantly improve profit so here my
learning from that is try to whenever
possible to quantify the action titles
include numbers in the action titles so
if you make a slide about profit of a
company usually you should always be
able to also put a number so what is the
profit improvement potential what is the
potential for the profit that you see in
the company next one when conducting
data analysis and interviews we learned
a lot about the business so this would
be an action title which very much
focuses on the process so what you did
you analyzed data conducted interviews
you learned a lot this is often not so
relevant people don't really care who
you talk to what analysis you conducted
what people are interested in are the
results this is one of the key
fundamental principles of top-down
communication again i don't want to go
too deep into this in this video but i
will link another video that i did about
top-down communication that buffer check
it out really one of the most
fundamental concepts for communication
as a consultant but also in general in
any professional environment last
example here results indicate
significant potential to look into
further improvement measures for the
business with the goal to increase
profits by 50 until end of this
financial year for the company so frank
i don't even know what exactly this
means the point that i wanted to make
here is write action titles in a concise
way don't use more words than necessary
yes usually there will be a full
sentence but don't just write for the
sake of writing the rule is that usually
in the title you should not have more
than two lines of title so two lines are
fine but not write more than two now
let's put your action title writing
abilities to test you see here a
standard slide it's from a mock-up
presentation of course not any actual
client engagement but what you see here
is a slide where the action title is
missing and i won't know you to come up
with an action title and now to happen a
little bit out here we'll just like
briefly explain what you see here so
here you see a sizing of a growth
potential every potential for this
company that could choose to enter these
markets so the north america market or
the asia pacific market and then you see
different numbers you see the market
size you see how much of the market is
covered by competitors a current market
share and other considerations like this
and in the end also an avid potential
that the company could receive from
entering these markets now i would
encourage you to maybe even pause the
video for a moment and think about for
yourself what would be a strong action
title for such a slide if you won't even
write it down so let's look into a
couple examples of what you could have
written so the first is derive
potentials for an expansion and again
feel free to always pause and think
about this for yourself whether you
consider that this is a strong action
title or not because indeed i would
argue this is not even an action title
this does not even meet the definition
of an action title this is a title in
the style that i know many people like
to do it but just not what i would
recommend you to do and this is for
instance if you have a page that
describes the risks of a certain
strategy than just writing risks in the
title right so it's a title but it's not
an action title in the sense that it
doesn't summarize the key message of a
slide in a full sentence next one
expanding to new geographies creates a
positive abbott potential abbott by the
way for the uninitiated stands for
earnings before interest and tax it
pretty much is one metric of profit
right so what is the profit the profit
potential of the company so what do you
think about this action title and here i
would argue that yes it meets the
definition i mean it is an action title
following the definition but i would
argue it's not the best action title
that you could write because indeed this
seems far too generic you could be much
more tangible much more concrete here
but let's look into a couple of other
examples expansion to north america and
asia pacific creates a positive abbot
potential i mean yes i like it it's a
bit more rich of information we're not
just talking about geographies but
already mentioning the geographies
you're interested in but here qualify if
possible we just looked at these best
practices whenever possible especially
whenever you have numbers available at
your disposal put them in the action
title and quantify it next one expansion
to north america and asia pacific
creates a positive ability potential of
22 euro million so yes hero would argue
it's fine it's already a very strong and
solid action title though here you could
argue that this is still a little bit
too wordy you could write this in a bit
more concise way usually the fewer words
you use the better so here one example
expansion to north america and asia
pacific with 22 euro million avid
potential and i would argue that yes
this is a good and solid action title
here what's also important to understand
is then you want to write these action
titles you do not need to write them
like you would write like proper full
sentences in a book it's completely fine
to take out certain words of new take
out articles any other filler words
which are not absolutely necessary to
understand the key messages obviously
you would probably not write something
like this as a full sentence in the book
but here's a concise action title this
is absolutely fine so hope this makes
sense to you so i know that in the firm
learning community there are many other
people who are also quite experienced
with action titles so if you have any
tips or insights or other comments on
this video please leave a comment below
in the comment section i trust that we
would all very much appreciate that
maybe you've already noticed that this
is a remake of a video that i did is one
of my very first videos on this channel
i just felt like the video back then was
not really up to the level of the
quality that i do the videos today and
the topic is just so important that i
just wanted to do an update on that hope
you still found interesting also if
you've already watched this quite old
video and if you've watched it thank you
for watching from learning for that long
i would never have thought that i grow
to the point that i do right now when i
started in january 2020 thank you for
being here with me since the beginning
as always if you took any value out of
this video at all please hit the like
button for the youtube algorithm and
also subscribe to this channel to stay
up to date on all my content if you want
to see more from me i also create
content for linkedin instagram tick tock
and twitch links to these socials in the
video description there you can also
sign up for my email newsletter and of
course last but not least the big big
thanks to all the members of the channel
you're really making a difference for
from learning thank you so much my name
is heinrich i release videos every
single saturday so see you again next
week until then bye bye